Und das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Machts gut.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So Leute, bin da.
Es hat sich alles, es hat sich alles ein bisschen verschoben, weil ich so lang gestreamt hab' heut' Morgen.
Das heißt, ich hab' heut' ja erst um 15 Uhr gegessen, weil stream, oder 14 Uhr, 14.30 gegessen, weil stream, das heißt, ich mach' jetzt Abendessen grade.
Passt wunderbar.
Exzellent.
Und wir müssen uns den Epic Sax Guy geben jetzt dabei.
Was ist das für'n Ubisoft Event? Das ist Ubisoft Forward.
Das ist irgendeine Ankündigungspresse Event, frag mich nicht genau.
Also, was gibt's da?
Ok, das ist fake, das läuft noch gar nicht. Das geht erst in 24 Minuten.
Wow!
Hat er gerade seine Hose irgendwie? Aber was auch immer.
Gatschi Base.
Ähm...
Das Ganze gibt's auf Deutsch? Warum das denn?
Ach, das ist Untertitel.
Lull.
So, das ist YouTube. Wie kommt man da jetzt auf die offizielle YouTube-Seite?
So.
Ok, wunderbar.
Ja, keine Ahnung, was da rauskommt. Irgendein neues Watch Dogs, Far Cry, frag mich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken, ich hoffe, es wird nicht so cringe wie andere Sachen.
Aber ich muss erst mal noch ein paar Stücke Pizza essen.
Und mir den Epic Sax Guy geben.
Bin ich eigentlich, im Chat sind noch nicht so viele da, bin ich der Einzige, der Sardellenpizza mag?
Oder gibt's hier noch ein paar...
...any Sardellas in Chat?
Sardellenpizza ist beste.
Die meisten Leute, denen ich das erzähle, die sagen, Alter, ist das eklig, Sardellenpizza.
Nein, Sardellenpizza ist das beste.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Sardellenpizza, Leute, ist einzig wahr.
Any Sardellas.
Es gibt auch noch, auch noch eine andere Sache, die extrem nice ist.
Auf Pizza.
Also wie gesagt, auf der einzigen, Sardellenpizza, huge.
Ja, sieht dann so aus, mit Oliven, genau, genauso sieht die aus, die ich gerade hab, fast genauso.
Oliven, Sardellen, manche machen noch so Carpone drauf oder so, ist nicht so meins.
Oliven, Sardellen, excellent.
Was auch richtig gut ist.
Bacon.
Moment, Baconpizza mit Sauce Hollandaise.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das schreibt.
Wie schreibt man Sauce Hollandaise?
Sowas hier.
Leute, am besten, Procoli muss ich sagen, am besten noch Hähnchen dabei, Hähnchen.
Richtig, Poggers.
Pizza Flying Dutchman, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das kippt.
Das ist, das ist auch massive, Poggers.
Also Bacon, Hähnchen, Sauce Hollandaise und Oliven, Sardellen.
Also zwei, zwei verschiedene Pizza.
Also einmal Pizza, Pizza Bacon, Sauce Hollandaise, Hähnchen.
Und zweite Pizza, Oliven, Sardellen, excellent.
Der Italiener dreht sich wahrscheinlich, oder die italienische Oma dreht sich wahrscheinlich im Grab rum, wenn sie sowas hört.
Das geht nicht als Pizza durch.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Zu viele Musikstreams, ja.
Ich brauche, ich brauche ohne Scheiß, wenn ich jetzt Pizza esse.
Ich meine, der Livestream, der geht in 20 Minuten.
Ich brauche noch ein bisschen Epic Sax Guy.
Ohne Epic Sax Guy geht gerade nicht.
Also Far Cry 6 wurde schon geleakt.
Also Far Cry 6 werden sie wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall was erzählen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, seit Far Cry 5, jetzt muss der Epic Sax Guy mal kurz aus Epic Sachsen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, seit Far Cry 5 und diesem komischen Addon, naja.
Also irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
Und ich habe es zu Far Cry 4 gesagt.
Ich habe sogar mal ein Video gemacht, Far Cry 4.
Ja, so.
Ich habe sogar mal ein Video zugemacht und da habe ich mich darüber aufgeregt,
dass im Prinzip Far Cry 4 einfach nur Far Cry 3 ist mit anderem Setting und im Prinzip sich sonst nichts geändert hat.
Und damals habe ich auch gesagt, okay, wenn die noch einen Far Cry 5 machen, was exakt so gleich aufgebaut ist, dann ist die Luft raus.
Und die Luft war raus, ja.
Far Cry 3 war das erste und letzte gute Far Cry.
Nein, Far Cry 1 war auch poggers.
Far Cry 2 war nicht so gut.
Mit Michael 5 spiele ich an, moin.
Far Cry 2 war jetzt nicht so geil, vor allem weil die Gegner respawned sind.
Aber Far Cry 1 war eines der besten Games bis heute, finde ich.
Eines der wegweisendsten Games bis heute.
Far Cry 2 war nicht so meins, Far Cry 3 war poggers.
Far Cry 4 war auch ziemlich gut, 5 für den Arsch.
5 war mir eindeutig zu Kokona.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Moment, Moment.
Ich muss...
Das muss jetzt sein.
Ich habe zu viele Fenster auf, ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Kokona.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent.
Endlich mal Freedom Musik.
Freedom Musik.
Also kann keiner erzählen, dass wir hier nicht international sind.
Wir haben Ami Country Musik mit Twitch Songtext.
Und dabei italienische Sardellenpizza mit Oliven drauf.
Ja, also da kann man jetzt echt nichts mehr sagen.
Das ist hier international.
Bildungsauftrag erfüllt.
Yep.
Twitch Emotes.
Hyping Dance Game.
Swift Trade PJ Salt and Failfish.
Ganz auswendig.
Easy.
All the time.
TOS was nowhere.
Everyone's feeling fine.
Jawoll.
Max, adde mal das Yep Emote für uns, nein.
Ich bin der Einzige, der hier Yep verwenden darf.
Auch wenn ich mich heute Morgen im Stream sehr für Meinungsfreiheit ausgesprochen habe.
Das hier im Twitch Chat ist keine Demokratie.
Emotes gibt es nur, wenn ich Emotes haben will.
Ich bin der Einzige.
Ich bin der Einzige Japper.
Twitch Emotes.
Der Franja.
Ich muss gleich noch mal schnell runter, mir irgendwie was zu trinken holen.
Übelst durche, nachdem ich jetzt die halbe Pizza auf die Schnelle reingedrückt habe.
Jetzt wo ich das Bild sehe hier.
Alter Twitch Chat, es hat sich am Twitch Chat nicht allzu viel geändert.
Mein Twitch ist immer noch Twitch.
Aber eins muss man sagen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie mit YouTube damals.
Es ist nicht schlecht unbedingt, wenn eine Plattform Mainstream wird.
Also sprich für die Content Leute.
Heute kannst du quasi als Berufs-Streamer,
wenn man einen gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad hat und wenn man irgendwas ordentlich Zeit rein steckt.
Heute hast du wenigstens die Chance als Berufs-Streamer zu überleben.
Aber ich muss sagen, als Twitch schon nicht ganz so Mainstream war, fand ich es irgendwie besser.
Wobei besser ist das falsche Wort.
Da fand ich es irgendwie mehr Pippo Happy Planket.
Trifft es ganz gut.
Versteht man was ich meine?
Warum schaust du kein Tatort?
Was?
Tatort?
Ich schaue überhaupt kein Fernseher.
Warum sollte ich ausgerechnet Tatort schauen?
Der Michael sagt, wie kann man sich das bei dir auf der Arbeit vorstellen?
Leute fragen, hey Max, wie war dein Wochenende?
Und du sagst dann, ja hat mich Pippo Happy Planket gefühlt.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Übrigens, nachdem ich manche Leute hier mal so ab und zu hier,
kann ich noch kurz was zu sagen, dauert noch 13 Minuten bis es losgeht,
was gerade vom Thema Fernseher hatten.
Und hier manchmal Leute irgendwie was von neuen Filmen und Serien erzählen
und mich fragen, so Max, guckst du Serien?
Ich gucke nicht so viel, aber ich habe in letzter Zeit zwei Serien geguckt,
die lohnen sich, vor allem wenn man Amazon hat.
Das hier fand ich echt ganz gut.
Die hier, das ist eine Amazon eigene Produktion,
also wenn man eh schaut Primad, kann man die sich angucken.
Die fand ich nicht schlecht, ein bisschen viel Love Story, Kitsch vielleicht nebenbei,
aber das Grundthema ist echt nicht übel.
Also wer Primad, dem kann ich das echt empfehlen.
Im Prinzip geht es darum, es kommt irgendein Programmierer,
kommt uns Leben und anstatt dass es jetzt halt hinüber ist,
darf er sich in irgendeinem virtuellen Afterlife ein bisschen austoben.
Aber ist da nicht viel Cringe?
Nee, gar nicht.
Die haben das wirklich gut gemacht, ohne Scheiß.
Man sieht auch, dass die dort ein paar Berater am Start hatten für Technik.
Das ist nicht so weltfremd, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Die stellen das so da, die haben sogar Microtransactions eingebaut.
Die stellen das so da, als könnte das wirklich sein.
Die haben sogar Microtransactions eingebaut, das fand ich eigentlich ganz witzig.
Und jetzt gucke ich gerade nebenbei, das ist von BBC irgendwas,
da habe ich vorhin die ersten zwei Folgen geguckt.
Das geht in eine ähnliche Richtung, auch quasi Zukunftsvision.
Fand ich auch nicht schlecht, oder finde ich auch nicht schlecht bis jetzt.
Aber Upload, wer Prime hat, sollte sich da wirklich mal angucken.
Ich fand es echt nice.
Guckst du keine A-Ja-Ja-Serien?
Doch, doch, ganz, ganz selten mal, doch.
Aber nicht oft.
Doch, ich habe auch in letzter Zeit mal zwei Folgen von einem Anime geguckt
und wollte weitergucken, aber habe dann bis jetzt noch nicht weitergeguckt.
Und zwar das hier.
Ist das Into Abyss?
Nee, doch, das da.
Das habe ich letztens mal angefangen zu gucken.
Auf einer höchst seriösen Streaming-Seite.
Weeps out, warum?
Okay, also zehn Minuten.
Ich werde jetzt mal ganz schnell mir was zu trinken holen,
damit wir rechtzeitig wieder am Start sind.
Ich finde, dass diesmal der Livestream nicht so wie bei...
Was war das letztens?
Was haben wir letztens geguckt?
Ach, Apple.
Ja, die ein bisschen Audioprobleme hatten.
Apple, übrigens.
Wir wissen es ja, warte mal.
Twitter.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Debated.
Apple, warte mal, warte mal.
Also ich kann mir ihn ja gar nicht angucken, aber das fand ich ganz witzig jetzt.
Alter, jeder muss irgendein Statement machen.
Es genauso wie jeder auf Twitch ein Statement machen muss zu Mental Health und sonst was.
Jeder muss zu irgendwelchen Themen immer sich auslassen.
Nur ich nicht.
Tja, wo war es denn hier?
Apple.
Wo hat er das gepostet?
Zumindest Apple hat ihn gestrikt.
Auf Twitch.
Weil er die Apple Developer Conference, die Keynote gestreamt hat.
Und wer sich dran erinnert?
Ich hab die Keynote auch gestreamt.
Und ich hab die Keynote gestreamt, weil ich gesehen hab, dass unter anderem er auch die Keynote streamt.
Auch geil, oder?
Also der an dem ich mich orientiert habe, dass man was streamen kann, wird gestrikt.
Ach hier, ja genau, hier ist der Post.
Ja, genau.
Ich hab ja noch im deutschen Bereich auf YouTube rumgeguckt, so nach dem Motto wer streamt auch.
Und dann hab ich ihn gesagt, wenn er streamt, dann kann ich das auch streamen.
Tja.
Hab ich schon mal Glück gehabt, da ich noch nie so groß bin auf Twitch.
Heysa hat auch gestreamt, vielleicht hat er aber.
Aber Heysa hat nicht auf Twitch gestreamt.
Heysa hat auf der eigenen Plattform auf YouTube gestreamt, keine Ahnung.
Ach was weiß ich.
Übrigens habt ihr euch mal gefragt.
Ich weiß, ich muss los, mir was zu trinken holen.
Aber acht Minuten haben wir noch Zeit.
Habt ihr euch mal gefragt, ich hab da zumindest so meine Theorie zu.
Warum ausgerechnet jetzt auf einmal die Leute so abgehen.
Mit Twitch Copyright und sowas.
Habt ihr euch mal gefragt, warum ausgerechnet jetzt?
Also ist das Zufall, dass das ausgerechnet jetzt kommt?
Na ja, bei YouTube hat alles geholt.
Nein, also das geht in die Richtung, was Easykiller schreibt.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass viele auf Twitch, also was viele Künstler Geld brauchen.
Jetzt dank Corona.
Und weil dadurch halt auch jetzt rumgeguckt wird, was ist hier los und Twitch auffällt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob daran liegt, dass Twitch auf einen Schlag bekannter geworden ist.
Ich glaube, es liegt eher daran, weil durch die Corona-Geschichte
so viele Leute, so viele Künstler jetzt quasi Geldprobleme haben.
Und die versuchen jetzt überall Kohle zu machen.
Und was ist am einfachsten, also auf eine Streaming-Plattform zu gehen.
Oder die Copyright-Organisationen.
Die versuchen jetzt alles überall das Ganze zu machen.
Bisher war es ja, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, auch nicht anders auf Twitch.
Also sprich, du durftest das ja offiziell noch nie.
Ich durfte offiziell noch nie hingehen und irgendwie Red Hot Chili Peppers abspielen.
Noch nie. Es hat aber bisher keiner großartig was dazu gesagt.
Was ich auch sehr nützt, sehr, sehr praktisch fand im Vergleich zu YouTube.
Man konnte im Livestream einfach machen, was man wollte.
Und die haben es halt so ein bisschen als nicht ganz autorisierte Werbung abgetan.
Und jetzt mit Corona, wo die alle mal auf die schnelle Kohle brauchen.
Jetzt kommen sie natürlich bei Twitch auf die Idee.
Wobei ich glaube, dass es ihnen langfristig wieder nichts bringen wird.
Das ist genauso wie früher, wo sie Napster und alle Tauschbörsen dicht gemacht haben.
Das hat ihnen auch langfristig nichts gebracht.
Die Leute haben es einfach bei der nächsten Tauschbörse geholt.
Es hat erst was gebracht, als es die Angebote gab, die gut genug waren.
Ja, und jetzt versuchen die halt noch mal ein bisschen Kohle abzugreifen.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es in Zukunft Regelungen geben wird,
dass Künstler und Copyright-Vertretungsleute offiziell die Rechte vergeben an Twitch,
dass man spezielle Titel, spezielle Libraries von ihnen abspielen darf.
Ist auf YouTube teilweise jetzt auch schon so, dass es Künstler gibt, die offiziell sagen, darf man.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass es in Twitch auch über kurz oder lang kommen wird.
So, ich gehe mal schnell was zu trinken, hol es mir gleich wieder da.
Und in der Zwischenzeit, in der Zwischenzeit, wo ich weg bin,
ihr müsst, ihr müsst den EpicSucksGuy ertragen.
Der Beste.
Ne.
Pepe, please.
So, wieder da.
Ach, ich habe es ja ganz vergessen.
Ubisoft ist das ja auch mit der Division, oder?
Das Spiel war es komplett an mir vorbeigegangen.
Wir hatten mal einen Azubi, der war ultra der Division-Grinder.
Und der konnte gar nicht verstehen, warum ich schlecht fand.
Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
So, EpicSucksGuy.
Wir können schon mal die Sound-Lautstärke einstellen.
Was ist das für eine Grafik?
Das sieht ja aus wie 1995.
Was zum...
What the fuck ist das für eine Auflösung?
Ah, Playstation, verstehe.
Moment, Twitch, Ubisoft, Forward, gibt es das auch auf Twitch?
Da ist die Quali vielleicht besser.
Okay, welcher Stream ist vorne?
TheCrew2, Rainbow Six Siege.
Welcher Stream ist schneller?
Twitch?
Was, schneller?
Ja, okay, Twitch ist viel schneller, wir gucken Twitch.
Da kann ich auch den Sound besser machen.
Was ist jetzt los?
Oh hier, jetzt geht es aber ab.
Oh ne, please, ich muss ausmachen.
Ausmachen, kein Sound.
Copyright.
Huge Song.
Dragonfall.
Lautstärke, wie ist das so?
Soll ich Ticken lauter machen noch oder passt so?
Passt, okay.
Ja, ich glaube passt so.
Chat, genau, den Chat.
Auf geht's.
Ubisoft, yes, oui, oui, oui.
Die Franzosen sind am Start.
Ja, Lautstärke passt.
Okay.
Also.
Ist das Watch Dogs?
Krass.
What is happening?
Moment, das ist aber kein Quote von ihm.
Und am Ende kommt der Cam for me.
Von was ist denn das?
Das ist nicht von ihm.
Ja, das ist nicht in-game Footage.
Live Footage, da müssen wir glaube ich nicht drüber reden.
Ja, so sehen echte Hacker aus.
Genau so mache ich das auch immer.
Ich hecke immer fahrend auf dem Bus.
Es hat einen coolen Style muss ich sagen.
Was rockt übrigens?
Mit 15 FPS.
Alter, warum sind das alles so Hipster Hacker immer?
Was ist mit dem seiner Nase los?
Was ist mit dem seiner Nase, Alter?
Ach, das war auch nur eine Maske.
Ach, der.
Das sieht jetzt eher nach in-game Grafik aus.
Warum gibt es da nur Hipster?
Sogar die Oma ist Hipster.
Aha.
Gut geht, Captain Price.
Er erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Ghost Story.
Sie können ja Kevin Spacey fragen.
Der hat Zeit gerade.
Oh, das Dark Web.
Was?
Die Musik macht mich übelst fertig.
Und die Hipster Oma ist wieder da.
Die haben sogar einen Zauberer dabei.
Ja, richtig cool laufen.
Es fällt auch nicht auf.
Das fällt auch überhaupt nicht auf.
Das ist komplett Stealth Assault.
Oh Gott, was ist das Ding?
Amy ist ein Drohnexpert.
Was haben wir hier?
Ein echter Techniker.
Ich hasse Spiegel, aber ich liebe diesen.
Was für einen wunderschönen Creepy Crawler.
Okay.
Warum hat die eine Gasmaske auf?
Guck ich mir an.
Das ist London, ja?
Da wey.
Zu Lull.
Ich versuche mir gerade ein Bild drauf zu machen.
Das sind alle Ubisoft-Games vermischt.
Ein bisschen Division, ein bisschen Assassin's Creed,
ein bisschen Watch Dogs, ein bisschen Far Cry.
Man muss wahrscheinlich wieder...
Was ist das denn?
Scheint doch kein zu schaden da.
Ist das Bulli 2?
Das ist aber Rockstar, ne?
Der Typ sieht ein bisschen aus wie Bulli.
Oder der Typ ist ja nicht Bulli.
Wie ist er? Keine Ahnung.
Wusstet...
Wusstet ihr, dass Watch Dogs und Assassin's Creed im gleichen Universum spielen?
Also, die könnten sich hier eine echte Assassin holen.
Woher weiß man das? Weil Abstergo erwähnt wurde in Watch Dogs.
Es ist ein Game, das möchte echt krampfhaft cool werden.
Das möchte krampfhaft cool wirken.
Oder finde ich auch?
Das möchte einfach krampfhaft cool wirken, wenn ich mir das da angucke.
Die hipster Leute, die Musik dabei...
Krass.
Also Hardcore...
Wir wollen cool sein.
Ja, wir haben das mit dem Fahrrad kaufen wollen.
Wir haben die Freiheit, die Details zu wählen.
Und wir haben viele Möglichkeiten, die Geschichten zu erzählen.
Ich habe die Fähigkeit, Dinge zu entdecken, wie kleine Eier.
In AC Unity gab es ein Fahrrad in der Welt, das mit Katzen geführt wurde.
Und dann ist es wieder passiert in Watch Dogs 2.
Und es kann oder kann nicht in London sein, dass es ein Fahrrad mit Katzen geführt wurde.
Ich war glücklich, letztes Jahr in E3 zu gehen.
Einige der Leute, denen ich unsere Demonstration zeigte, waren aus London.
Also egal, wo ich sie in die Stadt gelegt habe,
sie sagten, oh mein Gott, das fühlt sich an wie Camden.
Das fühlt sich an wie den Süden, das fühlt sich an wie Westminster.
Wenn die Leute etwas darüber reden, das ich in die Welt gelegt habe,
und sie sind gespannt darüber, das fühlt sich so gut an,
als jemand, der diese Welten mit Beachtung baut. Ich liebe es.
Und jetzt ein paar News für Brawl-Holo-Fans.
Battle Royale. Mit Battle Royale-Modus. Es braucht heute alles Battle Royale-Modus.
Denen, das ist so ein bisschen Smash, oder? So minimal.
So ein bisschen Smash-Verschnitt. Mobile-E-Sports, null.
Ah, das sind Charaktere aus anderen Ubisoft-Games.
Das habe ich jetzt erst kapiert. Ich bin ein bisschen langsam manchmal,
so ein bisschen low-brain, aber das sind teilweise...
Okay, da waren richtig gute Games bei, muss man sagen.
Also mein Lieblings-Might & Magic ist eindeutig immer noch der Heroes of...
Nein, nicht Heroes of Might & Magic, doch Heroes of Might & Magic,
der Third-Person-Source-Engine-Ego-Schnetzel-Game.
Beste. Und es ist ein Mobile-Game. Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Who cares? Oh, Mobile-Game! Geh weg!
Did also raid Shadow Legends.
Fortnite. Rainbow Six, Fortnite.
Rainbow Six Battle Royale. Rainbow Six Battle Royale.
Es sieht aber echt hart nach Fortnite aus.
Pass auf, Pass auf. Rainbow Six Battle Royale.
App Store. Okay, mobile. Mobile, please.
Zeig mal ein paar Games, die nicht mobile sind noch. Nein, mobile.
Ja, und ihr habt es am Anfang voll verkackt, aber danach gut die Kurve gekriegt.
Ihr habt den Anfang mega verschissen, jetzt tut man nicht so.
Aber danach habt ihr es richtig gut gemacht.
Die Map kann ich mir noch erinnern. Wow, huge shot.
This is such a special moment and being at one year anniversary of Rainbow Six now, game being stronger than ever, more players today than we had in the past, it means the world to us.
We have a share of challenges.
Die haben damals geworben, ich war ja auf der Gamescom, die haben damals geworben mit ein Counter Strike für die neue Generation.
Das hat nicht so ganz hingehauen oder Counter Strike der neuen Generation oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber sie haben gut die Kurve gekriegt, das muss man echt sagen.
Ich bin froh, dass wir einen Franzosen Emote haben mittlerweile.
Alter, warum zeigen die immer irgendwelche Influencer Leute, die wild rumschreien?
Die sollen immer ein paar Pro-Games zeigen oder ein paar Ausschnitte davon, wo es richtig nice Plays gibt.
Man konnte die Videos einreichen, okay.
Ich finde Rainbow Six eSport sehr schwierig anzugucken als nicht Rainbow Six Spieler.
Ah, okay. Battle Royale, by the way. Jeder braucht ein Battle Royale Spiel heute und das ist das von Ubisoft.
Wenn da Spiele an der Story spielen.
50.000 Leute lebten hier und jetzt ist es eine Ghost Town.
Battle Royale.
Ich habe ein paar Gameplays davon auf Twitch gesehen von Leuten, die auch wirklich gut sind, was solche Games angeht.
Es sah gar nicht so schlecht aus, muss ich sagen.
Es versucht auch krafthaft cool zu sein, ja, aber das Movement über die Dächer fand ich nicht verkehrt.
Ob sich noch ein viertes Battle, fünftes Battle Royale etablieren kann, ich bin ja skeptisch.
Die sollten Gameplay zeigen, das Gameplay macht tatsächlich ein bisschen was her.
Also die meisten, die da spielen, werden sogar durch das Story halber spielen.
Wie viele Battle Royale Games brauchen wir noch? Oh, da gibt es auch ein paar.
Das finde ich erstmal wirklich ganz nice, dass es kein Rumcamp Battle Royale ist.
Ne, das Movement kann man nicht mit Apex wirklich vergleichen, so wie ich es gesehen habe.
Es ist noch viel mehr Rumgejumpe.
Es ist deutlich mehr Rumgejumpe noch.
Mehr Teile voll mit Low Gravity.
Das ist ein budget Tracer, budget Genji.
Sieht schön nach Microtransactions aus, sagt der Chat, mit Sicherheit.
Das sieht schon sehr, sehr nach Low Gravity aus, oder? Chat.
Also das was ich gesehen habe vom Gameplay lässt sich am ehesten beschreiben als Battle Royale Titan voll mit Low Gravity.
Also es ist ein relativ schnelles Movement, allerdings nicht so sehr links und rechts, sondern auch eher nach oben und unten.
Gibt es eigentlich Max-FPS-Kill und Passive-Xer? Nein.
Also rein von der Optik könnte die eins zu einzelnen Charakter sein aus dem Spiel.
Die würde exakt da reinpassen.
Das ist Budget Zarya.
Es schreckt mich doch nicht so.
Wobei ich mag den eigentlich, der ist irgendwie sehr cool.
Irgendwie mag ich den.
Ich bin ein großer Fan von Assassin's Creed. Ich liebe die Zeit, die ich in Assassin's Creed Odyssey gespielt habe.
Und ich kann nicht warten, für dich die Gameplay von Assassin's Creed Valhalla zu sehen, die jetzt kommt.
Als jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Jetzt zeig mal her.
Assassin's Creed Valhalla.
Korrekt.
Also das, was man im Trailer gesehen hat, war schon sehr weit vor der Realität weg.
Das sieht nämlich schon eher aus.
Ja und sie haben Fälle an, was kein Wikinger hatte in der Art und Weise. Egal. Scheiß auf historische Korrektheit.
Ah man kann auch als Vorspieler, okay.
Das ist mittlerweile, muss das so sein.
Wie? England ist voller Engländer? Nein.
Ey, tut nicht. Feuerfeile, please.
Wenn die die Gegner nicht sehen, wie haben die Bogenschützen dann die gesehen? Das frage ich mich jedes Mal, wenn ich den Trailer sehe.
Red Dot, Red Dot auf dem Bogen, ACOG.
ACOG auf dem Bogen.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Autos Grill.
Oh man, gerne mit dem Schiff fahren.
Au.
Oh man kann ratzen.
Okay, mit Crafting, Städte bauen, na gut.
Aber die Gegner sind immer noch dumm wie Stroh, Alter.
Okay, das ist natürlich eine Big Brain-Bewaffnung. Das ist eine richtig Big Brain-Bewaffnung. Schild, was es zu dieser Zeit nicht gegeben hat und eine Fahne. Exakt.
Genau so würde ich ihn in die Schlacht ziehen. Mit einer Fahne und einem Schild, was es damals nicht gegeben hat. Exakt.
Schön flüssig sieht das aus.
Okay, das jetzt wieder nicht.
Au.
Oh man.
Assassino, Assassino.
Okay, jetzt haben wir wieder alles drin.
Häuser bauen, craften, 30 Milliarden Side-Quests, Schiffe fahren, Crew aufbauen, Skillbäume. Ach du Scheiße.
Kisten, Türme erobern.
Okay, jetzt wird ja alles dabei.
Die Animation ist mega schlecht gewesen. Aber das kann ja noch kommen.
Was eine krasse Rede.
Beste Rede 2020.
Today we raid, tomorrow we build. Alles klar.
Direkt, das ist ja fast schon Mortal Kombat mäßig.
Das sieht gut. Also landschaftsmäßig muss man Ubisoft sagen, das können die echt.
Also landschaftstechnisch war jedes Assassin's Creed bisher echt gut.
Stadion.
Das ist schon vorbei.
Schon vorbei.
Ich bin gerade erst warm geworden.
Was, wenn es fertig ist?
In den Film?
Was ist das? Aber schön gemacht ist es. Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung was es ist.
Wir spielen aber ganz schön viele Leute mit, wenn es ein Film sein soll.
Far Cry? Far Cry 6 wird das jetzt.
Und könnten das die Entwickler sein von Far Cry 6?
Ja, das ist Far Cry 6.
Das war gut gemacht. Da kann man nichts sagen.
Ich flame ja gerne, aber das war echt gut gemacht.
Ob das Spiel was taugt? Mal abfahren.
Excellent.
What are you doing?
Breathe, Diego. Breathe.
The pin simply holds the handle in place.
It is only when you let go that this grenade goes boom.
Follow me.
Ich bin El Presidente. Das bedeutet, dass du irgendwann El Presidente werden wirst.
And our people, they do not know how to be happy. They are torn apart by opinions, noise, indecision, strangled by their own freedoms.
Even if you want what's best for them, if you only want to save them from themselves.
They will hate you, Diego. Everything you say, do, believe, will be wrong.
Und jetzt erstmal die Granate in die Menge, oder was?
They will answer your screams, call you evil, a monster, and give you this.
So you tell me, are you evil?
Are you a monster?
Because our country is like this grenade, except it has two basic parts.
Our people and you. And you must clutch them nice and tight or we all go boom.
You understand now?
Moment, der darf den sich runterfallen lassen. Die eigenen Wachen stehen vor dem Haus.
Der sprengt die eigenen Wachen kaputt und dann stürmen die Demonstranten da rein.
Das ist nicht Big Brain Move.
Also ich muss sagen Far Cry 6 hat mir mit Abstand am besten gefallen.
Aber mit riesem Abstand.
Okay, fertig.
Also ich muss sagen, ihr wisst ich flame immer ganz gerne, aber ich muss sagen, ich fand's gut.
Nicht unbedingt so sehr, dass was gezeigt wurde, sondern es war ungefähr 50 Minuten ohne viel rumgelaber.
Einfach gezeigt, was aktuell ansteht. Fertig.
Nicht so diese Sachen, die sie sonst haben. Sie haben keine Influencer gebucht.
Sie haben nicht irgendwelche Leute hingestellt, die 20 Minuten erzählen, ich bin so wahnsinnig excited auf das Game.
Und only in Far Cry und bla bla bla und hier und da, die haben einfach was gezeichnet und gut ist.
Und ja gut, von dem was gezeigt wurde. Far Cry 6 fand ich geil.
Also Far Cry 6 hat mir wirklich sehr gut gefallen. Assassin's Creed Valhalla.
Ich hab mich ursprünglich, als die gesagt haben, es wird ein Game, was zu dieser Wikingerzeit spielt, habe ich mich sehr drauf gefreut.
Weil das auch historisch eine Epoche ist, für die ich mich interessiere.
Nachdem ich den ersten Trailer gesehen hab und schon mal festgestellt hab, dass fast alles verkehrt dran ist, was verkehrt sein konnte.
War ich ein bisschen verhaltener und hab mir gedacht, okay, vielleicht ist es nur für einen Trailer.
Jetzt bin ich auch nicht schlauer ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin auch nicht schlauer.
Und insofern, die ganzen Mobile Sachen war drauf geschissen, juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Was hat man sonst noch? Watch Dogs.
Ja, Watch Dogs hat mich auch nicht großartig gejuckt.
Watch Dogs war mir zu Not getrunken, zu gewollt cool und zu hipster.
Was ist das? Far Cry 6 could be a prequel featuring a young...
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das was ist.
Das sieht immer überhaupt ähnlich.
Und außerdem war es doch... Keine Ahnung.
Guckt ihr die Bilder an? Okay.
Puh.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu weit. Too far stretched, oder?
Illuminati confirmed.
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Nee, eindeutig.
Eindeutig Illuminati würde ich sagen.
Cool wärs, ja?
Cool wärs.
Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Mal gucken, da bin ich echt gespannt.
So abwegig ist es ja nicht.
Weil ich meine, die wissen, dass Vars mit Abstand der beliebteste und bekannteste Charakter aus dem ganzen Far Cry Universum ist.
Also, warum nicht? Wär gar nicht so blöd.
Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Nun ja.
Das war Ubisoft Forward.
Wenigstens nicht so viel Bullshit und wir sind super excited und freuen uns und hüpfen im Kreis und spielen Flirte dabei.
Wie bei? Was war das bei Sony?
Welche Pressekonferenz war das mit dem Flirten-Mensch?
Flut-Guy?
Nee, ja. Sony. Sony war das mit dem Flirten-Typ.
Der Flirten-Typ, Alter.
Das war zu geil.
Was ist mit euch los?
Es ist bestimmt nicht einfach.
Und die Musik gehört da nicht dazu.
Wo ist der Flirten-Mann?
Das stimmt auch nicht. Das ist auch die Falsche.
Original.
Nein, sag mal.
Gibt es da kein Video von?
Ja, das ist das Original-Video.
Das war so schön. Wobei ich auch gedacht habe, was ist mit euch los?
Pete Smith hat gerade ein Video hochgeladen. Ja, das machen die öfters, habe ich gehört.
Mehrfach am Tag machen die das.
Auf jeden Fall nicht auf Twitch.
Der Anfang ist gar nicht auf Twitch, so viel ist schon mal klar.
In was für einem Zusammenhang wollten die den Flirten-Mann haben?
Für Ghost of Tsushima war das?
Oder für was für ein Game war das nochmal?
Ghost of Tsushima war das, glaube ich.
Moment.
Das ist auch nicht das Original. Das ist Undertale-Musik.
Hier ist der Flirten-Mann. Am Anfang war das noch echt.
Das ist so schrecklich gewesen.
Ja, was war Ghost of Tsushima? Was übrigens auch demnächst rauskommt.
By the way, habt ihr gesehen, Amazon hat ihr neues...
Haben sie verschoben wieder.
Auf nächstes Jahr. Ich weiß nicht, was bei Amazon los ist.
Erst haben sie ihr komisches Crucible-Overwatch-Moba-Abklatsch-Ding rausgebracht.
War übelst der Rotz, wollte keiner spielen.
Und jetzt haben sie ihr Spiel ein komplettes Jahr verschoben.
Das sollte jetzt gleich die Beta starten irgendwann.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was bei Amazon da los ist.
Wahrscheinlich schieben sie es offiziell auf Corona oder so.
Ich meine, die wollten 25. August starten und jetzt verschieben sie es im Jahr.
Ich weiß nicht, was bei Amazon los ist.
Ich sage euch ehrlich, besser ein Spiel verschieben, als einfach rauskloppen und es kommt totaler Scheiß raus.
Guckt euch bei Anthem an.
Haben die Devs davon nicht mal gesagt, dass die Lumberyard-Engine ziemlich kacke für Multiplayer-Zugs ist?
Das ist ja CryEngine unten drunter.
Das ist ja quasi eine Premium-Lizenz bei Amazon für.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die für Multiplayer-, dass die für MMOs jetzt der Netzwerk-Part für MMOs vielleicht nicht das Geilste ist.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wo es herkommt.
Ansonsten, eines der Probleme, was man so liest, ich habe von Game-Entwicklung her keine Ahnung, ist, dass die Doku für die CryEngine ziemlich schlecht sein soll.
Ansonsten.
Das Video ist gut.
Nee Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf, ich war nur on, dass wir uns die Ubisoft-Show da angucken, das Ubisoft-Event.
Ich gehe jetzt auf, gehe Szene putzen und mache noch ein bisschen Action mit der Katz.
Die braucht ein bisschen Ansprache.
Die macht ihr schon manchmal an der Tür.
Kratz, Kratz.
Und in einer Stunde, halbe Stunde, Stunde bin ich im Bett.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns Leute, machts gut, bis dann.
See you.